Meet 99
A Partner Company of Udacity
99 was born as an app
designed to link people to taxi drivers.
Along the years, our goal is to have
an increasing portfolio of products
and offer all kinds of transport
people use within cities.
What are the professional profiles
that we look for?
Passionate people who believe
they can make a difference in the world.
So they have a working purpose,
brightness in the eyes,
willingness to do things,
ownership, which we
fondly call 99rship.
We truly believe we got where we did
and achieved the success we have
thanks to the people
we managed to bring to 99,
the team we built.
With almost all our candidates
we do some kind of test,
something to get to know them better.
We do a cultural assessment,
since we have a strong culture
at the company.
My journey here at 99
was real fast in fact,
in terms of responsibility and learning.
I believe this is a very usual attribute
among these startups that begin
with a project that has value,
that has a purpose.
And attracts very good people at first,
people that are interested.
And things change
very quickly, overnight.
The greatest challenge
is having a lot to do.
The amount of things is huge!
You usually work at a very lean team,
so you have to be careful
on choosing what to do.
And you also need to do
a lot of different things.
You do not specialize in a single system,
you deal with a whole ecosystem
of different technologies.
At least here at 99
we have little red tape.
You don't go through lots of layers
for approval, things you need to do
for launching a new code.
And something I enjoy doing
is following the result of things.
We are arranged it in a way that
is famous for being brought by Spotify,
which is called squads.
Squads are multidisciplinary teams,
which is, inside the same team
there is one person who delevops iOS,
one who develops Android,
one responsible for the server part,
someone from product,
someone from Marketing.
We see Udacity
as a great potential partner.
Professionals really prove
to have lots of qualities.
Among them, there is one
we find very valuable,
which is the continuous
and endless search for knowledge.
The capabilities we look for in a person
are Java, Scala is a plus,
or native Android, native iOS,
experience with Amazon AWS,
knowledge of agile methodologies,
and experience working
at a large-scale app.
Get ready for the market